the whole play uh playthrough for the
first little nightmares is on my channel
so you can watch that if you want to as
well but let's hop into this maybe we'll
remember as we go in
gnomes maybe maybe is that what i call
it is that why everyone else calls it i
can't remember
yeah whatever they're all empty so in
this game you get to
have a little friend and everyone
thought it was co-op but it's not
[Music]
this is the end of the last game
okay because we had crazy ass powers in
the last game at the end
oh
oh where's someone else entirely we've
got this like trench jacket going on
we're wearing little little woohoo
bag of shame on our head i bet
everyone has done the same this game
they just see the big coat and they're
like
can i yes cape
nice okay how what what are the dues
how do i do the mechanics
okay how do i pick things up can i pick
this thing up
is it a block on the floor no
uh
oh made it nice
oh hi
guessing i don't want to go down there
there's a cage over here
i remember being very impressed by the
little animations the last time i played
it
hold up for us the first game
bye what is the controls r2
there we go
very pretty
it's a shoe
nice beautiful can i
can i chuck the shoe
that was a pitiful throw what was that
give the shoe back to the foot go on
be a good boy oh
oh girl i'm not going to assume agenda
give the shoe back to the foot go on
oh
it wiggled
it's that meat meat sack from um
inside
now what do i just jump woohoo
it's very atmospheric
it's got limbo vibes
oh yeah warlocks are the same reminds
you of limbo
yeah i've made her references to limbo
and inside
maybe they just uh oh is
oh my god that was way too close
i died are you kidding me
i thought i made it
there we go zero deaths
guys now what was it gonna say oh yeah
no i can't deal with spiders
i like opened up my phone uh
i was in the queue for the post office
and i was looking through my friend was
uh
on holiday and i was looking through her
pictures and she had a picture of like
loads of little animals and i was like
ah cool
and there was a big ass spider like a
close-up of a big-ass spider and i
freaked out and i screamed in the queue
oh gosh oh i didn't grab it
wait but is there anything down here
that i'm missing
anything down around this corner
just a dead end what about over
dead here okay
are they going to be little um i'm going
to call them gnomes
are there going to be little gnomes for
me to hug in this game as well i like
hugging the gnomes
even though by the end of a killed one
oh
that was such that was such a moment
i just expected to hug it and then like
ripped off its head
i was like did not mean to do that
okay what
i'm i'm guessing i press r2 to like grab
it
that's what i'm doing anyway
hit hit no she's not grabbing onto it
i've got to do though that's definitely
the right way so i've got to grab onto
it
okay i guess maybe i'm just being silly
i can't get up this way can i
imagine if i couldn't i just cheat the
game
i thought this was a hole for a second
no full damage not from this height no
luckily
look good for me luckily for me
yeah i'm probably just jumping off the
wrong part of the
rock maybe i'm not going there we go
i had a problem with that in the last
game the depth
i can never tell like exactly where i'm
supposed to be
thanks for the follow
prop booney
liquor
interesting name
oh i see
well
[Music]
i guess now we're gonna see if there's
full damage
[ __ ] that there is full damage
[Music]
oh bless him
he got scared
there we go
can we climb up these
[Music]
more shoes this game loves its shoes
it does though doesn't it there's loads
of shoes everywhere
come on shoes
this is a trap
yes hell yeah i gotta let them shoes
oh i can't take it with me sorry
this is it's literally like limbo 3d
i know it's what that was as i stepped
into it i was like i'm an idiot why did
i walk towards
the guts
hello can i take this can i do something
with this
do i have a weapon now i don't know
nice
oh well i've got to use the stick i
guess
i wish i could drag it like in front of
me
i can just walk like this just to see if
there's any
traps
don't trust it
oh here we go that works better than my
little circular motions
i think i can see it anyway
oh my god there are so many i thought i
saw one
not like six okay
hello
this is not a place for kids to play
oh pyramid head vibes the way he drags
his knife
i was um watching a lot of silent hill
news today
because i heard that apparently there's
like two seven hill games in the works
one from a japanese studio and one from
bloober
i need to read into it more and there's
also that mars landing that i really
need to look into
i see that like i think life on mars is
trending or something on twitter
oh
come on i can see it
my depth is way off right it should be
about here
oh [ __ ] sake too far forward
luckily there's loads of these pinecones
and they keep dropping down for me
perfect
there it is oh is that not it is that
not one
i don't trust it
oops didn't mean to do that
i meant to jump
yeah i was watching a a podcast of some
people that like
really do not like the idea of blooper
team handling science
and i can see why what's that noise
i'm just gonna try and disarm all of
them
then i also i also think obviously every
studio has a chance to grow
especially if they hire more people
and learn from where they went wrong
and blah blah i can hear
[ __ ] can you hear that
do i need to turn the game up if you
can't hear that i have to turn the game
up because
i'm not in this alone
scared
oh for [ __ ] sake i meant to jump with
the pine cone i can't jump the pine cone
i keep forgetting that
i have to try and
i think it's just this one here
there we go
okay good chris can hear it
and hackathon and fear no evil good
yeah i've given up on the hopes that pt
will actually be made i've just heard
too many rumors and like i just
i've been let down too many times you
know
so now i just don't believe anything and
then if it does happen
all the better
hello
beans anything over here just a toilet
seat
so
we're uh walking into the razzie 7 house
get off
welcome to the family son
that's disgusting whatever that piece of
meat is up there
that looks very faulty
i don't want to make any noise can i
open up the fridge
i can't achieve it
it's what's in the box on the planet oh
yeah
cool i'm glad we did that
someone's oops this piano what a
beautiful way to welcome
that was an abrupt end to that audio
[Music]
okay
is that the same humming as in the last
[Music]
game
[Music]
should we go left or right guys
do i have my headphones on the right way
[Music]
we're gonna go this way away from music
for now
[Music]
it goes up
can i grab this [ __ ]
get yourself a weapon
now we've got some uh pyramid head vibes
oh what is that
a monkey how do i use you
dude get use it
do something wrong oh it's a bloody
child
i'm sorry child
here's box head
i thought it was one of those stuffed
monkeys you're the ones that like play
music
oh it's our friend
maybe not she's been held captive
for a long days it looks like she's met
the gnomes
the dorms are in this game look she drew
them where are the gnomes i know you're
here somewhere where are they where's my
lighter i want my lighter back
there's a picture of light
[Music]
um
she goes
running up the stairs
why are you running for me are you
showing me the way out
am i scary
i mean i am a weird boy with a bag on my
head
[Music]
that's normal
[Music]
this game is so weird i love it
fitz's fences
[Music]
okay
she's so tiny oh he i'm sorry i keep
hello
yes
now you come here hey no you come here
okay let's do this
oh that was not subtle
come on let's go let's just get that
[ __ ] out
what's she doing come up here
[Music]
is she
i was looking for the shoes nikki i
couldn't really see i think they were
wearing shoes
i'm not quite sure what that means but
it could mean anything
come on let's pull this one oh can i not
pull that
i'll pull this one can we do this
come on
maybe i can push it
ah can you help me
thank you
caterpillars more feetsies
hmm so we've got to find a switch it
looks like
teamwork mode engaged
apparently i can look at my hats but
i've only got one
so what can we use uh to put in
that then maybe maybe something is in
here can i open up these drawers
okay so that's how we get back there is
a key up
oh yeah but we can only get that once we
fair enough
can i not open these
oh hello hello you gonna all right
oh no
bless me
oh of course when i'm alone that's when
the scary things happen
she's not alive is it
anything down here
i'm just delaying the inevitable don't
worry i'm
oh my gosh she's [ __ ] stuffed that's
disgusting
well at least she's not alive that's
okay we can handle that
i don't want another gangly arm coming
to grab us
i'm sure that'll happen soon though
something like that
thanks everyone for blessing my sneeze
oh sorry you want help but
yeah do you want my help i'm trying
what do you want me to do
i'm trying to help but
all right do i just need to get in
position
how do you want me to help you
because if i try and grab it you don't
let me
he's just like i don't understand
fair enough oh jesus christ
i missed again again again
here we go yes
[Music]
it's a magic key
where does it go
not over here again good
oh i guess maybe we can't get back
oh no we're going back downstairs again
whatever it is will be down there
oops that hurt
oh okay but it's not here
oh there we go
big boots big boots oh look at the tiny
feet
he's just leaving like a gazelle
can we go up here
can we push this
is that as far as that okay okay
i'm sure that's enough
oh no
okay so this is why i didn't hear us in
the house then
right what's the deal with this
dude
oh chris is like what's that sound
it's something being gutted
i think and skinned
that's so cinematic i love it
[Music]
it looks so [ __ ] creepy where are we
going
going through the door
we can't surely we can't go through that
hatch we're going through the bloody
hatch
are we pushing it so we're
why is she pushing it
oh
[Music]
she was a slow
right i've got to go the other way i
gotta hide behind the box
go go go go go
hi behind the box
oh this one is just army limbo i
remember there was a bit
like that remember we had to get back
jesus
excuse me
i like that he's got a hat on that's so
cute
yeah you want me to go with you i'm
gonna hold your hand what do you want me
to do
thanks for following running games
can i hold her hand i feel safer
oh my god oh don't like this
[ __ ] there's a [ __ ] bird there
that's gonna tell him that we're here
there's a bird over there too
oh this socks
i wish i had something to throw at the
bed
maybe you won't see me over here
maybe i can sneak around the other road
hola sebastian maybe i can sleep like
this
did i find a bug yes
can't see me i'm at the edge of the
screen
i don't know maybe this isn't the best
idea i don't know i don't like it
oh don't look it go back go back get on
my way little girl
i'm gonna wait till you yeah okay
now go now go go get on my way
gosh hey it went yeah
okay oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh
[Music]
how how did i get away with this
okay i need to just get in that hole i
just get that hole
don't tell me that didn't work
ah
what the hell why is it like john cena
oh right yeah dude
i worry that she's not gonna do it fast
enough i don't know if that makes us
lose the game or not
okay i think i've got to wait for him to
look like a certain way
how the [ __ ] is he not seeing us i don't
know
just don't know
[Music]
this is stressful oh my god
i jump by accident
maybe if i just stay still like he just
won't see me
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
[Music]
could i hide in that bunch of leaves
[Music]
i'm getting way too confident
uh i haven't been told how to change my
character yet hbb
i'm right at the beginning
i did just gun it just not see nikki
not back then but my first time and i
got shot
okay so let's hide here by the grass
do you actually think i can just make it
just by like running
maybe i've got to hide like a little bit
further over here
no music's like
yeah let me go down
no no there's no [ __ ] way
yeah so i tried to turn his flashlight
so when it was right
like past me but i guess i can try when
it's left
just that worried about it easy just
outline the balance
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
there we go
hello are you okay oh let's get out
get out from the hole
uh where to
now little one
it's weird the colors keep changing
i like the side profile of like the
little
our little friend it's really cute got
like tiny tiny features like a little
tiny nose
i'm coming out of the spider
i look up traps
[ __ ] sake
[Music]
oh my god
and i guess she can do something on the
other side
for me or i just
hi how am i gonna get over there
oh my god really
jesus have you seen me
i don't think i can do this jump
i did it the leap of faith
yes i want to see you play a game where
you just constantly screaming
in a hurricane i think my throat would
be
just messed up after that
nah can't wait to see speed from this
game
you're watching the wrong streamer
i'm here for personality guys personal
personality
uh i hate these birds
oh wait it's a little yellow ring
hat reminiscent of the
last little yellow raincoat that we had
okay what what we doing up here is there
a reason for me to be up here
am i only up here to marvel at the
little yellow green
that was weird i kind of fell through it
a little bit
i'm gonna keep jumping on it and
hopefully it'll fall down or something
yellow rain hats
cute
see i'm not so scary now am i wearing a
little yellow rain hat
i'm still
i hate birds
and we're not going to blend in with
this bloody yellow rain hat
oh my god
i'm sliding
come on oh she can make it
i can't no i've got to stay there okay
so stay there
come on to the next box
up
gosh
i say
stay
jump go up up up up up up
up up up up up
oh my god
go
this is slushy
oh my gosh yellow hot it's so icky now
what what
am i gonna like die if i say yeah
and i make
where is he noise
can't they just like stay in this oi
what are you doing she's pushing me
can you just like say jesus
stay in the same place until like
oh my god i need to go no no
yeah until he gets bored i guess he'll
never get bored
i should just shut up
he managed to aim with me under the milk
oh don't swim with your mouth open
good advice
there we go we're like in sync
how do i get up can you help me i can't
seem to get up love why actually can't i
get up
what is she doing she's mad
she's a mad lad
we have to push down that tree don't we
so i do have to go up there
but how did she get up there like this
i was supposed to jump
there we go sorry
he's like what is that noise
oh he didn't notice
all right birds i'm gonna stay the
[ __ ]
as soon as i see a box i just gotta run
right to it
what everyone's talking about my primal
scream i never know what
what's screaming in
bone baby
ice cream a lot
okay we're gonna make it we're gonna
make it we're gonna make it
oh so cute teamwork teamwork murder
yes kill him
kill that was cool
what's that
oh we can't go have a look wanna see if
it's dead
can we see if it's dead
want to see if it's dead please
why not
[Music]
game
oh it's such a tease
fine
should we go sail away on this door
just me and you i've got my um my hat on
i'm practically a sailor now anyway
can you come help me please
no
[Music]
so stupid what
maybe i'm supposed to pull instead of
push then
no no i should be oh there you go now
she's out there
hey man
oh this is nice
set a message in the bottle let me go
get it
and they don't care
so
it's as if the world has just been
flooded
now we're gonna get to the area that we
left off in the first game aren't we
yes yes no
no this wasn't that
building's crumbling
[Music]
so
oh is there another little person over
here
what the hell oh my god
i got staticky it was weird
it was like not a real person this made
me all staticky
i know i'm supposed to go through that
door but i just want to have a look
around
you look through this door
bye rick's like thanks for joining
what's my opinion on the game so here i
can't really
say much i mean
yeah i don't haven't played enough to
say really
i like it about as much as the first
game
although she can be a little bit a
little bit annoying
that is the case with most um companions
though
especially if you're trying to do
stealth
because you need to command the space
but at least it's not like you have to
defend her
i wish we could hold our hands though
ew
i can't tell if that's like a skin suit
or if that's just someone's uh
like a playsuit it could just be a
playsuit
a playstation is basically a one piece
just kiss anyone didn't know
but i'm guessing it's not as uh
not as innocent as just a playsuit
oh toilet roll
i grab it yeah can i make a
oh i was hoping it would roll out you
know
and you could make little toilet roll
streams
but i guess not let's go
into this room here
if i could grab it oh
sorry
so many shoes if you want it's just
so many clothes can't put myself up on
that
can i get behind the bar
toilet roll physics will be on budget
damn it
this game would have been entirely no it
can't be
i'm wondering who these two are though
they're obviously
just completely
separate from the first game
but there's obviously some sort of
worldwide thing going on where they eat
tiny people or they use tiny people
to to stay
living for longer very weird
okay we're gonna have to oh hello okay
what about here i haven't found any
gnomes yet
[Music]
there was a hole behind those tvs that
wasn't fair
come on game
hey denise yeah i'm playing little
nightmares
and it's kind of like it's difficult to
explain because i
even i don't really know what's going on
even though i played the first game
but you're trying to run away from like
bigger people but they're not really
people it's like they're
it's like if they were once human and
then they've evolved to be something
more
grotesque and disgusting but they're
feeding off their
little people to keep themselves alive
either that
or it's like a race of aliens or
something else entirely like vampires or
something
um but they wear like skin suits
so they it's like they're trying to be
human it's very disgusting
oh sorry what did you want
she's yelling at me was i supposed to do
something or were you just saying bye
okay bye um
right i'm guessing what i do is can i i
know i know
i'm doing something
that was cool
she's over here somewhere
hi there she is hello
oh she's waiting for me
nice nice nice nice
vampire aliens from outer space
terrifying skin suits ooh
yeah very no the visuals are lovely this
this game looks
gorgeous i love its color palette
it's it's so strange because it it
almost looks cute and i think that's
what makes it even more scary
oh no i hate these jumps
how the [ __ ] is so far away
let's try that again
okay i better make it this time
ah good
oh i do know there's just those tiny
animations where like
they run past something and they just
they just run their hand over i just
think it's really sweet little
little uh tiny details like that i do
really like them i appreciate them
i know there's been there but i'm
wondering what's out here
but i i don't want to progress the game
what the hell
are these things
is it like memories or something
i don't know
and if that's
i don't want to progress i don't know
which way i progress ah
let's check out here first
try not to fall trying to fall trying to
fall
trying to fall trying not to fall
okay this this is the progression
[Music]
oh i thought it was a cut scene i'm
still moving
something about the tv
all right little one let's go turn it
off then
maybe you can turn it off by the plug
[Music]
oh that's so cool
[Music]
oh damn oh damn this is so cool it's
like
um was it like poltergeist or whatever
it is
that film what she's like on the tv
[Music]
what the frick so that's where we
started
[Music]
oh that was so cool
can we go back i want to see if there
was anything in that box
ah whatever
oh that was so cool i love that
there's something special about this one
can you help me get up here please no
never mind i don't need you
[Music]
so
okay i'm just gonna have a little look
around first
as always
i can't tell if that's a man in the
trash i wouldn't put it
i think that's also what this game does
very well it does a good job of like
showing you enough detail but not
everything so a lot is left up to your
own imagination like this
man in the dumpster i can't tell but
actually is a man
um it's very good at that the fact that
you never even get a proper glimpse at
the character that you're playing is
that's telling enough
oh it's the eye oh my god is this
cool
i love the camera motions in this game
as well
let me go back get out of my way
don't cough on me
can you push me push me
push me push me i push you
get on oh [ __ ] oh come on oh
devs why oh how could you not i
guess i guess it doesn't make sense but
oh come on just want her to get on it
and then i can push it
oh missed out on a good little moment
there
really i just can't believe we can't do
that
okay fine fine
oh how did i miss the goal
oh i found our way in by the way
it's right there are you gonna play
goalie
you be goalie
oh you saved it
all right let me try again
yes i'm the winner
so what happens if i go up to the door
nothing
that's fine get this ball though
what the frick it wasn't a ball it was a
hat
i thought it was a ball
oh it's a ball hat that's a bit creepy
oh we got ourselves a new hat
kick me kick me kick
kick me
she must find us so annoying what
um i didn't even see this here
what you looking at
okay i think that's everything we have
to look at here yeah there's a lot of
those eyes everywhere
all right let's go then
runs very enthusiastically
what investment he will see so you can
go down a slide and ride a panda thing
that's crazy that game
was not horror in the slightest resident
evil totally lost their way for a little
while
they're back on track now though that's
the main thing
a shoe would you like a shoe
does it fit you no it looks too big
never mind why
something's still burning in here
that's not safe
that's also what i like about this game
just the environmental things like the
the portraits so
bloody creepy i feel so messed up
i don't want to press that yet because i
don't know what it does
probably opens that door i'm guessing
but i'm gonna have a look through this
door first
wow this was not a fun place to be
are you okay oh
cough
i cannot get to the cafe
there's a little duck
these kids must have oh it's a paper
airplane oh
yes i love playing with these in the
last game
okay that brings it back up to a tent as
oh do you want to play with me
okay here we go look devs are
um redeeming themselves here we're gonna
play box
you're going what
that's not how you play blocks
fine where did you want to put this then
she did it well done i'm so proud of you
i got you a present
there's a little doll here do you wanna
play with it
oops
oh schneider sorry
i'm making a bit of a mess here
okay anyway i think we should go
oh no
see that's why i knew i shouldn't put
her eyes
there's something there
the destroyer of environments has left
her mark
i do have a reputation to uphold we know
this
oh i see the ball
that is spotlit
and they're like this because i know
where to stand
to get the right angle there we go
now i just got to jump up to it
okay someone was kept here for
a while
for 40 days what was that
did i just hear something
40 days at least like
before they were tied or maybe they got
untied every now and then
those tiny shoes again see these will
fit you
you ready for this
ah that was a shorter fall than i was
expecting
you know what i don't like this hat
[Music]
i think i think i'm gonna have my yellow
hat again
there you go i look cuter now
makes the game less scary
right question is who are we going to
come across here
oh when i stop head butting the beep
i think i can hear someone in the
distance
every now and then very faintly
could just be the music
oh my gosh
[Music]
um
why is there a duck
in a bucket
[Music]
it's a trap they knew i was gonna go for
the ball
i'm gonna turn the game up just a little
bit you haven't asked me to but
i just want to make sure you can hear it
because it's so good
okay stay away from the ball
hiding here
[Music]
oh my god i did it i touched i didn't
even mean to
i'm so proud of myself
i don't think these kids are friendly
should i go through the open door shall
i attempt to go down the hallway
oh my god can you see that kid
guys what should i do should i go down
the hallway should i go through the door
[Music]
what do you think this kid is just
staring at me maybe i should just throw
some paper at him
i see you
let's look at some knives and forks up
on the ceiling
screw it
go say hi lean him up once a minute go
say hi
thanks for following rj morales
502. nina wants me to say hi
i don't know buddy though i i'm just
going to keep checking this
oh i went the wrong way
i'm scared where the hell did it go
it
[ __ ]
i ain't falling for your tricks
there's a dream here
thanks for following where's arby
but i didn't fall for it
it's a small small wins guys you know
i'm so used to dying
anything i can take i will take it
basically just stick to the edges you'll
be okay
but she just recoiled what's this
drawing of
can we draw i want to pick up a prayer
oh did we just hold hands
oh my god it's so cute
i love it
yeah this game said outside
sorry right okay stop holding hands now
i love it hold my hand i'm scared
oh it's so cute
this is just what we need in the
pandemic when we can't be close to
people we just
hold hands in horror games
[Music]
sorry i should be scared
where is this thing
why is the camera pointing in that
direction
hello there's something in the locker
isn't there
not a fan of that hey
stuffed holding my hand
i'm scared though
something's gonna be in this locker i
don't trust this locker
i knew it
[Music]
what the hell are they they're like
oh hell no we need to grab that hammer
can we grab the hammer and then just
smash their
heads in what
starting with you mister
oh yeah i can't jump with stuff oh never
mind
oh so and that's why she stopped holding
our hand because
she had to be over there to right okay
she didn't do it because she wanted to
she had she had to do it because the
game told her to
i know i don't have attachment issues
what are you talking about
how am i going to get up there
maybe i have to i probably just have to
keep on playing don't i
and i'll find her again later on
friends confirmed is not nice they're
not nice let's kill them they're not
real
they're just dolls
we are a badass we're like as bad
as they come
[Music]
that was a bit delayed okay so we don't
need
the hammer for this one
yellow hat do you like the yellow hat
i wonder if it's gonna
i wonder if i can hide into that table
that would be nice i think i can
[Music]
what was it doing like dissecting a frog
doing science i guess i never did that
in school did you guys do that in school
hey six
hey thomas
[Music]
yeah i never dissected anything in
school i don't know
yeah i don't know how i would have i
remember at the time i i was like oh i
want to dissect things because i think
it was only the
highest science level class that got to
dissect and i was always in the middle
middle sets but now i'm like oh i don't
know
i don't ever like to do that
wow if 196 had sheep's
hearts does i say damn
okay now we need to get a bit clever
with it
can i open this door more no no no no
open open open i want to open
can i open
[Music]
something's happening
it's like the souls of
a large tower
i've just noticed that picture is a
picture of a dog just peeing
oh if 196 is only joking about the sheep
starts
wait or what are you joking about sucks
to be you
i don't know i can't tell
thanks for coming chris
where is it
let's take a peek let's see what we're
working with here
oh no it's chalkboard oh it's the worst
i hate chalkboard i hate chalk
i even hate chalky sweets i hate chalk
i hate the feeler talk everything about
chalk
see this game is great look at this you
still can't
see the big scary teacher
it's all obscured oh
um okay anything in this room that i
need
i don't know why this room is here
the kids better not wrap me out
oh she looks so creepy i mean i still
can't wait to see it
oh no the depth is freaking me out again
can i get closer i'm gonna try and get
closer guys
i see a slither of an eye
so weird
what what oh god
there's so many moments that just become
so [ __ ] terrifying in this game
some nowhere
run run run run run run run
her head came off
i thought i could do this
can i not oh i thought i could pull this
off and then go back around but
i know i have to hide in that little box
i'm guessing
oh denise is scared yeah i can see why
hey mama okay
pick up pick up pick up pick up wake up
[Applause]
oh my god
again oh now i go through the vents
oh god
she's right there not yet
yellow face oh
my god no i'm not ready i'm scared
oh okay and there we go
i'm scared
oh my gosh she's a [ __ ] scary lady
[Music]
scores are scary why did she draw a
mouse on the chalkboard
she should already smash this one
sculling
brave kid oh no
no no no no no no we're just going we're
going
we're going we're not part of this class
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
ah thing is though i mean schools
weren't they're scary but schools that
used to be scary like
my mom told me about the amount of time
she got like
wrapped in on the knuckles with a ruler
because she was dyslexic and dyslexia
wasn't a thing
back then so they just thought that she
was not listening
but she just had
you know problems
she just didn't find it as easy as other
people and she just used to get like
hit for it in schools horrible
guys it's a kid gnome
he's drawing a lot of eyes
should we draw with him all right he
won't let me look at the chalk
hello hi
oh god oh my god
it's not friendly i gotta stop being so
naive
mine oh whoa i thought i could wear your
hat then
let's go get that pole okay so i'll wait
for him to go
sucker
loser
something not all right with this one is
there
he's drawn that big tower as well that
we saw in the locker
as well as the eyes
oh i need to smash it
shut up nina i'm not bully
yeah what mate you're talking to me i'll
chin yeah that's what they used to say
in my school
i'll cheat you wait till we get
you wait till school's finished after
so i just hide in the toilets
[Music]
school i remember when i was school
people used to say school is like
the best years of your life lies
absolutely
can i look at this hat
can i not really
chin yeah what it meant like i know it's
a weird place but i don't it's what they
used to see back in
plymouth but it's like you know like
this
can i can i wear is this a hat can i
wear the plunger as a hat
i'm so animate i want to find a hat here
i just
you would have thought you'd be able to
wear this one as a hat but i guess not
hey ion
hey
where do i go
oh it's so creepy that she doesn't close
her eyes so she's just like
ah that's so scary
[Music]
the eggs have no hat here
sorry sorry
okay
there ain't no time like present young
one come on
oh schneider
up she comes i'm already down
i'm probably gonna get ready to start
winding down
soon by the way just let you know don't
want to have nightmares
okay okay
step step step
[Music]
what
fear i know evil's like get in the box
and hbb like just like my teacher
alright here we go
if she pokes her head back up now
oh i love that i love that i love this
design this is so good
i was just thinking if she pokes her
head back up now i'm screwed but then i
realized i can see her shadow
so i'm not screwed so i know what she's
doing but only like
in a very subtle way ah this game so
good
great atmosphere i love it
can i grab this so i can chuck it
oh please oh thank you bye
[Music]
hey
oh sorry i need to go here so you need
to move
put it down here
i'm guessing i ran up this bit
i might fall okay good oh my gosh
oh my gosh
everybody is like i don't talk like that
oh sorry hbb i'll call you because
is that
[Music]
look at it
she's creepy she's so pretty
[Music]
awesome uh left my computer for five
minutes when i come back to the smacking
sound in the background did i miss
something
yeah you miss you missed something what
i don't know i don't know if you saw the
um
giant necked teacher
uh but yeah that's that's what's
happening right now
this floorboard looks a bit odd oh no it
doesn't do anything
never mind
oh i think i was supposed to move that
somewhere
oh i see okay so if i move this one
great
there she is wait is this
this is the same teacher one isn't it
yeah it's gotta be
i'm sorry was that another hat that i
missed was it in here somewhere
let's let's go have a look i'd much
rather try and look for a hat then
do that again right now
denise okay i'm glad i'm not the only
one
it's like i saw her there but i just
didn't expect to like ram ahead through
a bunch of books
oh i think that's a hat yeah yeah i know
i can see it
they say knowledge is the most powerful
weapon through a book
um i can try but i
something tells me that's not gonna work
oh what i want this hat
i want the teddy bear it's fine a bucket
will do
three yeah okay
come on come on little one who got this
what now
[Music]
hello
[Music]
gosh you were going around earlier let's
keep on with that movement how are you
doing that
like this
what
she's gonna do the head thing again i
don't trust her
keep going just keep moving don't worry
about it it's fine
everything will be okay
i should stay behind the books
[Music]
maria's like i would love to have her so
granny
and then sam jones is just like
w2f like are you okay
oh
oh my god
this is so hard
i quite like these games the way you
have to learn from your mistakes
i mean
[Music]
so many games are so precious about you
like not ever dying
and like being perfect
so do i just have to move really
freaking fast
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
i don't even know this is hard
right this time i think i'm just gonna
wait forever
thomas this way here too wait here
how is that
she has a long slinky sneaky bean oh
did no go out of the room
i think she did i literally thought
though for a second that she wasn't
going to see us right by her feet
because she was so busy looking up at
the books
that would have been quite funny perfect
yes
can we go back to the way that she where
she was
uh i'd really
i think i'm lost oh no here i am
okay now
i guess i'll go in and grab that door
handle
oh baby feats can't do it
let's drag this box it's got drag marks
so that probably
means
ruin the goblin what we're talking about
goblin what goblin
there is no goblin
hey
okay it's saved so i don't know whether
to stop playing now i probably should
really let's play until i die again
no i didn't play the dlc's tamas i just
played a little nightmares
it's really not a very tidy place is it
did we miss all the cool hats did i walk
right past them
i hope not
and nikki's like die again when did you
die
[Music]
okay there's no one around
oh look is that our friend no probably
not
in the portrait oh yeah we're still
looking for her i forgot about her
sorry i forgot she existed
or that she'd ever left
it's the poop poopy doggy again
oh let's put this back together be
helpful
oh that's so creepy that picture of the
kids
okay so that's obviously how i opened
that door but
uh could i actually go around this way
or not
no there's nothing here okay
fair enough
i'm getting so confused looking at the
show it's like despot
turkish cowboy okay so much for
emotional attachment
i'm not gonna admit you have a point
because you don't have a point
oh you put it back on the thing
is that kid's head in the chest piece
or is it a kid hiding in the chest piece
or is it a kid's head on our friend
that's our friend what the hell
thanks for following audrey kenny
no that's not her
[Music]
that can't be her
okay i need to get up there somehow
what the frick can i move these pieces
around
i need to go up and get that uh oh
there's a sword there
what to do with this
oh thank god you guys are saying it's
definitely not her good
i just saw her tiny feet oh yeah but she
didn't wear shoes
no that's not her
do i need to get that chest piece up
there i think i do i just don't know how
to get up there
i want to get a sword
not fair
oh maybe i'll go and get the um
the top from the chess piece outside oh
there's
bloody there's more to the room fair
enough didn't notice that
yeah if i take this off then i can uh oh
no i can use it in this room
uh is there something in here do i need
to get that
nope
no i want to climb up it
see for most climbing things you press
r2 to climb up the ledge so i'm pressing
r2 to climb up this but then it's just
taking it back off again there you go
let's put the king next to the queen
then i guess
oh that's not this one
i thought that would do something
you know what the clothes that's weird
just blacked out for a second the clue
is probably in the next room so let's go
have a look at that
they're all wearing the little gnome
hats aren't they
oh we can pull this down
facing which way
[Music]
okay that's that one it's uh then the
queen's in the corner
okay so i've done that
[Music]
oh no that one's right actually isn't it
yeah that was right yeah this one's in
the corner
[Music]
yeah see i i i do like little nightmares
because it doesn't hold your hand
and you get to just explore and just
have fun with it whereas like
like when we were playing this game it
was very hand holdy
apart for that one part jesus christ
what just happened
[Music]
what did we do
[Music]
the lights turned on
there's a door somewhere
oh i absolutely agree who said that
man has i don't like
uh just so many games are like so open
world and somehow
it's it just feels like a lot of games
trying to do like a bit of everything
and
honestly i just liked a few things done
well i don't need
everything in a game because i don't
have time for that
has maybe one of these doors out here
unlocked
hmm what have we done
no that needs a key
yeah well
i don't even just think it's like
there's it's just so many
good open world games i know i'll never
get a chance to play
because i just don't have the time
it's the peeing dog
amazing we've been seeing this
peeing dog everywhere
bye
[Music]
i also think that little nightmares um
for me
anyway has good pacing like it has
a good mixture of uh intense
anxious moments um but then
more laid-back puzzle
type moments it's probably going to go
back into an action
some games like outlast especially
outlast two
um i think outlast one wasn't so bad she
was quite good but
outlast two jews by the end of the game
it was just run run run run run run hide
hide hide hide run run run run hide hard
to hide it and i was like oh
i didn't even it wasn't scary it was
more just like annoying
because you'd run away from one thing
and then another thing would come and
you have to run away from that thing
and it was just too much
okay
sausage hello boy
would you like a sausage
oh that might be the first game
lovely
oh my god what is gonna this is gonna be
all the freaking kids
eating dinner isn't it
what kind of kind of games do i like to
play oh jesus
uh well i like to play horror games
obviously um
uh i love which three some of my
favorite games are like
bioshock
but also i like games where
you get to like explore and you get
rewarded for finding
things around the environment and
perhaps it's not about
killing it's more about i don't know
just
being observant and getting to know i
love it when
a game has good fleshed out like wow
lore as well um so beyond good neighbors
one of my favorite games as a kid
um so many games oh the arkham game is
so good too so so many games games like
that
oh no i did it too early i couldn't tell
i should really stop and go to sleep
i'm gonna carry on playing this i
remember this happened with the first
game didn't it i just
couldn't stop playing so i have to kill
them all can i just kind of
stealth fast
let me try and stop
[ __ ]
[Music]
i thought he was up there just like
hitting the food
okay guys i'm going to try and time this
right
but it's when they stop let's yell at me
don't mess with me and my big spoon
maybe i could wear his head as a hat oh
i can't hello
i am scary trying a child
my name is what what should my name be
i am scary china child and
my name is
i don't know
[Music]
there you go sydney thank you my name is
charlie the china head
oh god i have to pretend to be one of
them i am one of you
i am a
[Music]
they are
[Music]
the one up sitting in the corner oh yes
like here that's the type of ones you
need to look out for
[Applause]
hello my name is charlie i'm just like
you
i can dance too look i got a cool trench
coat on
[Music]
hello my name is charlie
so good
i can't move guys
[Music]
that one
oh this is so good
what's she doing to his head
[Music]
[Music]
do i help that
[Music]
i girl i probably shouldn't
[Music]
no no i should
what's in here
gosh if that's not enough to put you off
kids i don't know what is
oops
i tried
there's a brain in that jar maybe it's
one of the sheep springs that like if
had to
do stuff on what went to er right i see
oh gosh
am i going towards the brain
why
okay maybe i'm gonna like the brain's
gonna smash on the floor and then i can
use the brain
uh i guess that's what's happening here
then yeah
i'm gonna use the brain uh
is there a quicker way to get down i'll
just
where's the brain gone here it is
oh nice squashy squashy squishy
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
should we see if she wants the brain
pinky and
the brain brain brain brain
here you go teacher do you want it
suppress it for you
i think she's gonna eat it she likes it
is she gonna come back
gonna stay in there because it's her
dinner time
yeah she's staying in there
hello
that's weird you've got that little eye
but
there you go
what's she eating
[Music]
see she should have been happy that we
got her a brain she obviously has a
collection going
you could use it as a piece of ring
hey tammy
hit her with the spoon
no no no no no austin
she's so scary
okay i'm calling it there i'm gonna hate
myself though oh no i shouldn't
no i really should like at least just
get past this bit and then i don't have
to come back in the game
and do this straighter because i'd hate
that right
what did i do wrong guys
i don't think i should go this way
so i didn't make a noise did i she just
saw me for some reason
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay well that worked
luckily i don't know what to do though
apparently i can climb up
am i using these books
[Music]
oh crap oh no
oh god okay this makes life a lot harder
she's not eating she's playing with
hearts
oh my god she's not gonna turn around
again now
she's just getting more hearts out
what's she doing now oh god god
go go go go go go go what's she doing
what is that what did you just draw
she really doesn't know what to do with
herself does she
[Music]
juice go up
i don't think i can go that way oh i
can't
okay i really should stop now
right i'm gonna stop we'll look for our
friend
in the next uh the next episode or maybe
that's like the end game is like looking
to see where our friend's gone maybe we
won't find her until the end but
we will find out um
next time next time
i like i like this i mean i i really
like little nightmares one
anyway but this is great as well i'm
sure you can tell as i play it i
point out things that i really like
about it um and
just the freaking the first guy that you
have to run away from
in little nightmares one with his long
arms i mean
she is basically him but with her long
neck and i just hate
i just hate that just because you don't
really know
how far away you can be um
safe you don't know where the safety
zone is because they can just keep on
growing
oh it's just and anything like that
that's
it kind of like veers into the uncanny
valley because it looks
human it looks it looks normal to an
extent it looks like something that you
that you understand that you know but
there's
something fundamentally wrong about it
and it's just so
so creepy i mean uh i know a lot of you
know that i love junji ito but
his stuff it's a lot of like body horror
and
uh oh i just find it so terrifying
because it's little things that
maybe we could maybe it's because we
think of it in ourselves
so i know he has things like maybe
someone will have
a spot and that'll be what it is but
then it turns out to be like a massive
gaping hole in their head so that's like
to another dimension or something and
and then it's just like oh can you
imagine because we all get spots
and then i'm sure we all have these
weird thoughts it's just like what if
this
spot is gonna leave a gaping hole in my
face and what if it actually does
and then something worse comes out of
that hole like ah i still have stuff for
that but anyway
i'm enjoying this i will see you guys
next week thank you so much for joining
me it's been it's been a lot of fun
i enjoyed this i'm i think you guys are
enjoying this as well right
you can tell me but uh i have a feeling
you are
enjoying this
ah what are you saying about a yes
ostrich neck
yes yes they have seven you guys very
observant
uh the first one is awesome yeah it is
no
these games these games are very good
very good very atmospheric
very beautiful um but also
they they understand they understand
what makes a good survival horror game
you know the sound design is brilliant i
think mantas said that earlier the sound
design is
excellent in these games and it's just
that the small things like when
when i was on the ledge and i i could
see her shadow
so i knew like when she was about to
come up before
her head having to actually be in the
shop which gives me just a little bit
extra time because timing is everything
in this game um
and they do they do try and give you
some help here and there you know like
when you're
hitting the the clay people
the china dolls and then they'll stop in
their animation
and you know that's the time to it's
just about learning that
and it's really fun